hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today i want to discuss the projection
operator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics as the name says
the projection operator projects one
quantum state onto another
but why would we need to do that there
are in fact many situations in quantum
mechanics where that is necessary
one that you're likely to use very often
is that when we measure a property of a
quantum particle
quantum mechanics tells us that the
state of the particle collapses
onto a different state the projection
operator allows us to mathematically
describe this collapse
this means that before we can learn
about any of these things we must learn
about the projection operator
so let's go to define the projection
operator we start with a ket
psi that we take to be normalized the
projection operator associated with this
cat
which we write p psi is defined as the
outer product
of psi with itself and before we proceed
check out the video on operators if you
need a refresher about other products
now that we have defined the projection
operator we want to understand what it
does
to see it we consider the action of the
operator on an arbitrary cat
phi we write out the projection operator
explicitly as now to product we then
rearrange this expression
and we set the bracket here between psi
and phi as a scalar c
we can move a scalar to the front and we
obtain c psi
and here c is the bracket between psi
and phi
so what does the projection operator
associated with the ket psi do
it acts on an arbitrary ket phi and
gives us another ket that is
proportional to psi
additionally the proportionality
constant is given by the overlap between
the initial state phi
and the state psi that defines the
projection operator
this is the reason why we call this
operator the projection operator
it projects an arbitrary state onto the
reference state psi
we can draw a simple analogy with what
happened in the familiar euclidean
vector space
in two dimensions the euclidean vector
space is spanned by
x and y and if we consider two vectors
a and b then the projection of the
vector
a onto the vector b is this vector shown
here in red
and we can calculate it as a dot b hat
in the direction of the b
vector where b hat is the unit vector in
the b direction
what we get after projecting a on v is a
vector along b
whose length is the scalar product of a
with b this is analogous to what we get
after projecting phi
on psi which is a state along psi with
length given by the scalar product
between psi
and phi now that i have introduced the
projection operator
the next thing i want to do is to study
some of its properties
the first one is that the projection
operator is edem potent
that means that it squares to itself to
prove this let's write
p psi squared we then insert the
definition of the projection operator as
an outer product
we then rearrange this expression and we
find that the scalar product here is
equal to 1 because the state
psi is normalized and this means that
this expression simplifies to this outer
product
which is simply the projection operator
itself
so that it makes sense that the
projection operator is squares to itself
if we project an arbitrary state onto
psi once we get a new state that is a
long psi
if we then try to project this new state
again we're already alongside
so nothing will change in the second
projection so it makes perfect sense
that applying the projection twice
is the same as applying it once in fact
the then potency is a defining property
of a projection operator
any operator whose square is equal to
itself is a projection operator
the second property of the projection
operator is that it is hermitian
to see this let's consider the adjoint
of the projection operator
which we can write as the adjoint of the
outer product
and remember from the video on operators
that the adjoint of an outer product
simply reverses the order
so in our case we get this and it is
simply the projection operator itself
now i want to look at the eigenvalues
and eigenstate of the projection
operator
let's start by writing the eigenvalue
equation p psi acting on eigenstate
lambda gives the eigenvalue lambda
multiplying eigenstate lambda
we can then replace the projection
operator by its definition as an outer
product on the left hand side of this
equation
and we realize that here we obtain a
bracket that gives a scalar that i will
call
c we can therefore rearrange this
eigenvalue equation as c
psi equals lambda lambda where c is the
bracket between
psi and lambda how can we solve this
equation to find the eigenvalues diagram
state of the projection operator
there are two possible solutions the
first one is that the eigenstate lambda
is equal to psi
in this case c which is equal to the
bracket between
psi and lambda then simply becomes a
bracket between psi and itself
which gives 1 because psi is normalized
this implies that lambda which is equal
to c
is also one the second possibility is
that lambda is orthogonal to psi
this implies that c is zero and in this
case lambda is then also zero
so these results make sense an
eigenstate of an operator is a state
that when you act on it with the
operator
it is only multiplied by a scalar but it
doesn't change direction
for the lambda equals one case we have a
state that is already along the state
onto which we're projecting
so it will still be parallel to that
state after the projection
for the lambda equals 0 case we have a
state that is orthogonal to the state
under which we're projecting
which will indeed give 0 when acting on
it with the projection operator
so it is perpendicular to it
next i want to discuss a very useful
property of the projection operator
which is that it allows us to write any
ket as a sum of two other cats one
parallel to the reference get
psi and one perpendicular to it
to see how this comes about consider an
arbitrary ket phi
then insert the identity operator then
add and subtract the ket
p psi phi which simply amounts to adding
0
and rearranging this last expression we
obtain this here
each of these two terms is an eigenstate
of the projection operator
to see this let's start with the first
one p psi acting on the first term
gives us psi squared acting on phi
remember that the square of the
projection operator is equal to the
projection operator so we obtain
p psi phi this equation tells us that p
psi phi is an eigenstate of psi with
eigenvalue 1.
for the second term we can also consider
p psi acting on it
and operating through we obtain this
and then the squared projector is equal
to the projective so the whole
expression gives us zero
this means that one minus p psi acting
on phi is also an eigenstate of p
psi with eigenvalue zero
so what does all this mean we can pick
any cat
phi and write it as a sum of two other
cats like this
the first is parallel to psi and is an
eigenstate of the projection operator
with eigenvalue one
and the second is perpendicular to psi
and is an eigenstate of the projection
operator with eigenvalue zero
what we just found about writing an
arbitrary ket as the sum of two
different cats is a feature of vector
spaces that appears in many different
contexts
consider two vector spaces u and w that
are both subspaces of another vector
space v
if we can always use a vector in u and
the vector in w
to write any vector in v as the vector
sum of the first two
then we say that u and w span v
and write it like this
furthermore if this decomposition is
unique which is equivalent to saying
that u
and w only share the identity element on
the vector addition
then we say that v is given by the
direct sum of u and w
and write it like this when this happens
we call u and w
complementary subspaces
if we compare this to what happens with
the decomposition up here
we see that an arbitrary state phi in v
can be written as the sum of the two
states an eigenstate of the projection
operator with eigenvalue 1
which belongs to a subspace we call v1
and another eigenstate of the projection
operator with eigenvalue 0
which belongs to a subspace we call v0
additionally the eigenstates of the
projection operator are perpendicular to
each other
so that v1 and v0 are complementary
subspaces
and we can write v as a direct sum of v1
and v0 one very common
way in which the projection operator is
used in quantum mechanics is to project
onto a subspace
of the whole state space the most
convenient way of writing this down is
in terms of basis states of our state
space
for basis u we consider a subset of
basis states u1
to un which span an n-dimensional
subspace of the full state space
we then write the projection operator
onto this n-dimensional subspace as p
n and it is equal to the sum from 1 to n
of the outer product of the basis states
in this subspace
to confirm that this is a projection
operator we start by calculating the
square
to check that it is equal to itself
because you'll remember that this was a
defining property
of a projection operator to do this we
first write out
explicitly the projection onto the n
subspace twice
we then rearrange this expression by
moving the sums to the beginning
we then use the fact that we're working
with an orthonormal basis
and this allows us to reduce the double
sum into a single sum
and this last expression is equal to pn
confirming that pn is either potent
so it is a projection operator
we can also look at how pn acts on
arbitrary cat phi
and we obtain this expression here
as expected the ket pn phi lives in the
n-dimensional subspace of state space
as it can be written in terms of basis
states u that live only
in this subspace so that the sum runs
from 1
to n to recap we have defined the
projection operator p
as an operator which is e then potent
meaning that it squares to itself
as examples we have considered the
projection on a ket psi
and then the projection operator is
written as the outer product of psi with
itself
and we have also considered the
projection to an n-dimensional subspace
of state space
spanned by n state in a particular basis
we have also found that the projection
operator has two possible eigenvalues
one corresponds to eigenstate which are
parallel to the state under which the
operator projects
and 0 corresponds to states
perpendicular to it
finally we have seen how we can write
any cat phi as a sum of two terms
one parallel and one perpendicular to
the state psi onto which we're
projecting
the projection operator allows us to
project a quantum state
onto another or onto a subspace of the
full state space
projections of quantum states find
applications in all sorts of areas
from some of the most basic quantum
mechanics concepts like measurements
to more advanced topics like systems of
quantum identical particles
you can find links to all these topics
in the description
if you like the video or you like send
me suggestions for future videos please
subscribe